My girlfriend is quite overweight,
but I really love her.
Should I try to encourage
her to lose weight?
Aside from personal preference,
is this likely to explode into
a major issue down the road?
I don't think that you can fool yourself
about what you're attracted to and yes,
it's certainly likely to develop
into a major issue down the road.
Um,
it's tough,
you know,
uh,
because it's so,
okay.
The devil's in the details,
you know,
should you try to encourage
her to lose weight?
I guess the question is how would
you do that without disrupting the
relationship?
Um,
yeah,
and without knowing more
about the details of that,
I would say that I don't know how to
tell what to tell you to do about that.
I think that it's necessary to be
truthful in a relationship period.
But I also think that you
can't use the truth to hurt,
you know,
the truth is a very
complicated thing and it's,
it's a sword and it cuts and
you can't use it to hurt.
Now,
you know,
maybe you would be subtle enough to
figure out some way that you could both
embark on a health promoting endeavored
together and that would work out.
Um,
but I would say,
you know,
if you,
if you're in a stable long
term relationship with someone,
it's pretty much necessary for both of
you to address all the issues that are
making you unhappy with each other.
Um,
you know,
assuming there's some give and take on
that because otherwise the relationship
can easily come apart at the seams.
Like I would say my wife and I are
both very hard on each other about our
physical appearance,
let's say.
And I had gained a fair bit of weight
from the time I was say 40 until the time
I was 50 about probably because I was
eating things that weren't good for me.
And I would say that was
primarily carbohydrates.
I can tell you if you want to lose weight,
you stop eating carbohydrates,
man,
you'll lose weight.
Like you wouldn't believe.
Um,
I wouldn't necessarily recommend
it because it has some dangerous,
but it certainly works.
But you know,
the,
the alternative to protect
to the alternative is to
pretend that everything's
all right.
And all that means is that you're likely
to get drunk sometimes and some day and
have an affair out of
bitterness and spite,
and the fact that you're no
longer attracted to your partner.
So it's pretty rough.
So that's pretty rough way
of thinking about things,
but life's pretty rough.
So.